the rest of the stuff in here is just
more business card how many business
cards do you walk around oh yeah hey I'm
Kelsey I'm Garrett and today we're
playing what's in your bag
women versus men I will just like to
preface this bag by saying I do not
bring this like day to day this is not
like she goes to Target she brings this
bag this is like my day to day work bag
I don't pack this heavy normally but
this is my bag
it's a promo character that I love from
overwatch
it's a diva very cool looking back thank
you and then I've got a Sailor Moon
little keychain and then on this side I
got my reusable water bottle that has
all my little colorful bands that I can
move as I drink it needs refilled is
that how you like to tell how much water
you've had during the day next we have
my Nintendo switch I was gonna guess
that you had a switch gonna be like I
bet she has a switch I have my
sunglasses and then I got my switch
charger because that thing runs out of
battery on long flights
what are you playing on switch right now
right now I'm playing a Fire Emblem but
I'm also playing breath of the wild I'm
still trying to be because I'm just
always playing it at the background
between games here's my wallet with all
of my wallet II things I've got a bunch
of business cards in here we'll just
have that to represent umbrella front
it's like a Good Omens umbrella which is
a book and show that I like deodorant
pair of headphones my laptop and then my
tide to go pen cuz I'm a messy girl but
I got a little good on camera this is
always in high demand yes and that is
that is pretty much it the rest of the
stuff in here is just more business
cards in the bottom of the bag how many
business cards do you walk around with
oh yeah they all fell out of the
container they were in so now I just
have a law on the bottom so yeah so this
is all the things that are in my bag fun
right now oh wait edit lip gloss but
that was in your bag there's like less
than I actually thought was in that Bay
that bag looks pretty full yeah but it
looks like pretty much just essentials
and things that I would associate you
with like the your laptop your
headphones your switch I sort of assumed
alright so what's in your bag okay yeah
sure
mine you show me yours this is my
backpack that I walk around with boy
it's a pretty big backpack but I'm a
pretty big guy it's from Chrome I've had
it for a few years I really like it it's
pretty simple
yeah got pocket yeah let's see what
pocket I've got my wallet a charger
he's a actually plug for it and here's
some place to earpods easy is like
everyday I've got that sleek in
comparison backup headphones in case I
forget my ear pods
car keys and house key Burt's Bees so
that's like oh another Burt's Bees
to birds notebooks so that's a notebook
these are all notebooks whoa this is a
book I'm reading it's not very good but
a friend really told me to read it so
I'm fighting my way through it but I
usually have a book on me to read that's
usually really the only thing is that
like downtime thing yeah yeah uh-huh
you don't have any like pens or anything
these are pens oh my laptop or my phone
okay my digital Val pens I really like
hotel pens so I try to steal those my
laptop a script that I'm working on that
sort of goes with this stuff too like
you're organizing at all I know you're
like I really wanted to make it look
nice I just was like that
my car's registration that I need to put
on my car cuz I just got this in the
mail last week oh I need to check on
that thank you for the reminder yeah
sunglasses and then so like I don't work
here anymore it's like whenever I come
here I like sort of stock up on lacroix
so that's what's really in here it's
just a lot of Lucroy I have to pay for
this stuff now there used to be a time
when I get this for free and now I get
it for free when I come in and do
so I cry I'm thirsty God you have your
little band system yeah I have my kin
system that's it that's everything
that's in this bag that's a big bag a
lot of it makes a lot of sense it seems
kind of similar you have like a thing to
do work stuff
I like that your headphones there's much
smaller than my headphone it's probably
much smarter move and then the little
Croix I think was the big surprise of
just packing in the Lacroix yeah but I
mean that's great
that's so funny to me I think I'm
surprised by how similar they are to be
honest I always kind of assumed that
guys travel real light workwise as we
both actually have similar stuff the
deodorants smart actually maybe travel
around with you around and I'm surprised
you have the tide pen everybody should
have one but nobody ever does
that or people just lie and say that
they don't actually have a tide pen when
they really do I bet that happens a lot
I bet that does I do feel like I know
you better
[Music]